Welcome to another
Stories From The Stores
I'm here with curator Katie Dabin and
today we've got a Dewar flask...
So this is a dewar flask for storing heads or brains in liquid nitrogen for cryogenic neuro-suspension.
Is there a head in there?
Thankfully there isn't because that
would cause all sorts of headaches!
Okay but that sounds super sci-fi, super like Futurama.
It sounds like a mad idea, but the reality is in medicine we use freezing all the time for cells and tissues
Think about IVF, we store embryos and sperm and cells, so it's real science.
How does it actually work?
What you need to do is preserve the brain and the head,
so you need to rapidly cool it to stop any cellular activity or any decay happening.
You've got to take it down in three hours to stop any ice crystals forming
and then there's a longer two week process of taking it down to -196 celsius
and then these body parts are preserved for the future until they could be brought back to life.
I'm pretty sure people like Walt Disney
and some famous people have had this, right?
Walt Disney was rumoured to be
frozen, but he never was he was actually buried
and in reality there's only been about 150 people who have been frozen by the
Alcor Life Extension Company - where
this object comes from - and 33 pets!
The first person to be frozen was Dr James Bedford and he was frozen in 1967,
he was an American professor of psychology at the University of California.
Is this an unusual object for the museum to be collecting?
I think it's a really important object for the museum to collect
first of all it represents how a small group of scientists and members of society are responding to one of
mankind's biggest challenges - how to
overcome death
and really interesting ethical issues about how we think about the future
so are you you if your brain was put into a
different body, how long should somebody live for?
What rights would you have if you were living in the future if you were revived?
So you're a curator, would you want to be preserved like this?
I think even if medical science catches up and you could live with all your personality and memories,
I just think ultimately living in the future will be quite a lonely place, would your friends and family be there?
And I just think really you would be a dinosaur living outside your own time.
You've got to understand that you haven't dissuaded me at all. I should live forever!
You should go for it.